dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr karo jonai feher
in this paper you will not only see an
amazing technique
for two-way coupled fluid solid
simulations
but you will also see some of the most
creative demonstrations of this new
method
i've seen in a while but first things
first what is this two-way coupling
thing
two-way coupling in a fluid simulation
means being able to process
contact you see the armadillos can
collide with the fluids
but the fluids are also allowed to move
the armadillos
and this new work can compute this kind
of contact
and by this i mean lots and lots of
contact
but one of the most important lessons of
this paper
is that we don't necessarily need a
scene this crazy
to be dominated by two-way coupling have
a look at this experiment
with these adorable duckies and below
the propellers
are starting up please don't be one of
those graphics papers
okay good we dodged this one so the
propellers are not here to dismember
things
they are here to spin up to 160 rpm
and since they are two-way coupled they
pump water from one tank to the other
raising the water levels allowing the
duckies to pass
an excellent demonstration of a proper
algorithm
that can compute two-way coupling really
well
and simulating this scene is much much
more challenging
than we might think why is that note
that the speed of the propellers is
quite high
which is a huge challenge to previous
methods if we wish to complete the
simulation in a reasonable amount of
time
it simulates the interaction incorrectly
and no ducts can pass
the new technique can simulate this
correctly and not only that
but it is also four and a half times
faster than the previous method
also check out this elegant
demonstration of two-way coupling
we start slowly unscrewing this bolt
and nothing too crazy going on here
however look we have tiny cutouts in the
bolt
allowing the water to start gushing out
the pipe was made transparent so we can
track the water levels
slowly decreasing and
finally when the bolt falls out we get
some more two-way coupling action
with the water once more such a
beautiful demonstration
of a difficult assimilate phenomenon
loving it
a traditional technique cannot simulate
this properly
unless we add a lot of extra computation
at which point it is still unstable ouch
and even with more extra computation we
can finally do this
but hold on to your papers because the
new proposed technique can do it
about 10 times faster
it also supports contact rich geometry
as well
look we have a great deal going on here
you are seeing
up to 38 million fluid particles
interacting with these walls given with
lots of rich geometry
and there will be interactions with mud
and
elastic trees as well this can really do
them all
and did you notice that throughout this
video we saw
a lot of delta t's what are those
delta t is something that we call time
step size
the smaller this number is the tinier
the time steps with which we can advance
the simulation
when computing every interaction and
hence
the more steps there are to compute in
simpler words
generally time step size is an important
factor in the computation time
and the smaller this is the slower but
more accurate the simulation will be
this is why we needed to reduce the time
steps
by more than 30 times to get a stable
simulation here with the previous method
and this paper proposes a technique that
can get away with time steps that are
typically from 10 times
to 100 times larger than previous
methods
and it is still stable that is an
incredible achievement
so what does that mean in a practical
case
well hold on to your papers because this
means that it is
up to 58 times faster than previous
methods
58 times whoa with the previous method
i would need to run something for nearly
two months
and the new method would be able to
compute the same within
a day witchcraft i'm telling you
what a time to be alive also as usual
i couldn't resist creating a slow motion
version of some of these videos
so if this is something that you wish to
see make sure to visit our instagram
page
in the video description for more this
episode has been supported
by lamda gpu cloud if you're looking for
inexpensive
cloud gpus for ai check out lambda
gpu cloud they've recently launched
quadro rtx 6000
rtx 8000 and v100 instances
and hold on to your papers because
lambda gpu cloud can cost
less than half of aws and azure
plus they are the only cloud service
with 48 gigabyte
rdx 8000 join researchers at
organizations like apple
mit and caltech in using lambda cloud
instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lambdalabs.com
papers to sign up for one of their
amazing gpu instances today
our thanks to lambda for their
long-standing support and
for helping us make better videos for
you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time